so as we continue our discussions on DC
rebirth what I want to do here is I want
to dive into Titans rebirth number one
now there's a couple of things that I
want to do with this because again that
you know I exist here to explain comics
and so the idea or at least what I want
to do is I want to run over both Donna
Troy and I want to run over the whole
new 52 Titans Teen Titans dichotomies
because for a lot of people this is
proved confusing right you know for a
lot of people they've kind of been in a
situation where they're like Woodward of
the Titans stand where the Teen Titans
stand what's going on with DC rebirth
how does this all come together how does
this all work so with regards to Donna
Troy let's start with her first because
she'll actually allow us to segue into
the Teen Titans and the Titans
themselves Donna Troy was originally
created by Robert Kennedy I think and
she was designed to be the Superboy
allegory for Wonder Woman which is to
say where Superboy told the stories of
Superman when he was a kid and set the
foundation for a lot of the villains who
would grow up to become foes of Superman
as an adult Wonder Girl was designed to
tell the stories of Wonder Woman as a
little girl while this was really
successful in its idea its execution
proved to be difficult due to the fact
that in 1965 I think DC came along and
they said hey let's create the Teen
Titans now I have a video that explains
a Teen Titans which you'll find down in
the description but DC had looked at the
success of Dick Grayson they had said
Dick Grayson doubled and tripled the
sales of the Batman and detective line
of comics with his introduction because
he was a teenager fighting alongside
Batman and young people really loved
that they also began rolling over
various sidekicks and so on which
bolstered the sales of those respective
heroes and so because of that DC and
braven the bold numbers 60 I think said
let's launch Teen Titans win Teen Titans
was created by Bob Haney it was more or
less a call for all the the younger
superheroes to join a single team and
whether it was due to a lack of
communication or whether it was due to
the fact that Bob Haney just didn't
really care what was going on with
anything else he grabbed the character
of Wonder Girl and threw her onto the
team now this originally created
confusion and the reason why was because
on one hand you had stories during the
impossible tale line of comics that
dealt with Wonder Girl being a little
girl telling the history of Wonder Woman
when she was a child on the other hand
people were sitting down and they were
reading Teen Titans and Wonder Girl was
in the
des and so there was there was really no
reconciliation there there was no way to
know what was going on people were just
kind of left to their own devices now
eventually DC came around in the the
time before crisis on Infinite Earths
and they said well here's the origin
story of Wonder Girl she's she's not
ignore all that stuff about impossible
tales ignore all this stuff about Wonder
Girl being a younger version of Wonder
Woman here's the story of Wonder and
what they said was that Wonder Girl was
basically a little girl who was saved
from a fire by Wonder Woman she was
orphaned and as a result Wonder Woman
took her to the mascara and had a race
which basically led her down the path of
becoming the equivalent of Wonder Woman
among the Teen Titans now because of
Teen Titans sort of waxed and waned
because the stories had popularity but
they also fault her with regards to the
multiverse and and all the things that
went into the continuity issues and the
confusion among fans when Marvin Wolfman
and George Perez rebooted everything
with crisis on Infinite Earths in 1985
they also revisited the origin of Donna
Troy and what they said was that Donna
Troy was now one of like 12 orphans I
think from across the cosmos who was
designed to fight a war on behalf of
gods and that was the problem with her
character was she constantly received
reboots because she was so intertwined
with the character of Wonder Woman due
to how she looked due to how she fought
due to her equipment so on and so forth
that DC had to keep them close they
couldn't just make her off on to her own
character because anybody who got into
DC Comics would say well who's this
character and why does she look like
Wonder Woman and so because of that over
the course of her publication history
leading up to the new 52
there were retcons there were changes
there were all kinds of events that took
place when we got around to the new 52
DC came back and they said okay here is
the origin story of Donna Troy Donna
Troy is a character who was created for
the purpose of usurping the throne of
Wonder Woman and Themis Kiera DC did
this by launching a series called Titans
hunt as well as telling that story
within the Wonder Woman line of
publications now this allows us to segue
into Teen Titans and to the Titans
because of the fact that when the Teen
Titans were launched originally again
because they were so popular they became
a mainstay of DC Comics and in fact
there have been a couple instances in
DC's history where the Teen Titans have
actually outsold the Justice League for
a respectable amount of time when I say
respectable I mean for a few years the
Teen Titans at one point were the most
popular team in the history of comic
books they even did better than Chris
Claremont
and he wrote that for 17 years so that
really tells you how popular they were
the problem was that over the course of
their history they waxed in Wayne they
again you know experienced slumps in
sales and so on and they were cancelled
and brought back several times but there
was always a desire for fans to see the
original Teen Titans operating as a team
and so while the team Titans themselves
saw a changeup in rosters and things
like that DC launched a team called the
Titans and the Titans were basically the
original team Titan members on a team
themselves maybe not the original but
they were basically the most popular
versions of the Teen Titans on a team by
themselves led by Dick Grayson this
proved to be wildly popular if people
absolutely loved it the problem was that
when when new 52 came around and be seen
blushed a line wide reboot the Titans
vanished instead they were replaced with
the Teen Titans led by Tim Drake the
reason why I say this was a problem was
because on the whole is largely
considered that the Teen Titans stories
in the new 52 were not very well written
there were a lot of people that loved
them but people who loved the pre new 52
Teen Titans didn't like what they were
seeing in the new 52 and because of that
their sales were just continually
slumping I mean you can go you can look
at the sales month by month and you can
see them just dropping off continually
and so what DC did is they came back and
they said okay fine if you guys want the
original Titans we'll give you the
original Titans and they lost a story
called Titans hunt now again Titans hunt
was basically a return of the original
Titans but it was very limited and it
happened in the blink of an eye because
almost immediately after DC came back
with Titans hunt and said hey there was
an original Teen Titans team before Tim
Drake it was wrecked conned out of
existence now the reason why it seemed
to have been retconned out of existence
is because of DC rebirth what this
Titans DC rebirth number one does is it
comes back and it basically tells us
about the Titans themselves now again it
initially picks up with Wally West now
for those of the guys who have not been
following my my videos on the flash I
and the rest of the rebirth a DC be
worth content that I have the situation
of Wally West presents two different
issues for the DC line of comics and
what I mean here is that what goes on
here with regards to the Titans and
their ability to remember Wally West is
a totally different situation from
what's going on with the overarching DC
rebirth event the overarching DC we
worth event establishes that somewhere
along the
The Watchmen character dr. Manhattan who
has godlike powers had done something in
the DC Universe and it basically screwed
up continuity now we don't really know
what the future of this is going to be
and I'm sure there's going to be some
major crossover event that happens
probably a year within the launch of DC
rebirth that will cover all that and
will tell us where things stand it may
even be a crisis of sorts that sort of
reshuffles everything and sets
everything back to a status quo and
creates one cohesive universe but right
now Teen Titans are I guess the titans
line of stories deals strictly with
Wally West and why the Titans couldn't
remember who he was now again this
basically picks up with memories it
picks up with Wally West recalling his
life as part of the Titans before the
new 52 there talks about everything that
he remembers fighting alongside the team
but then it also reestablishes the fact
that they don't remember who he is and
the reason for this is simply because of
the fact that their minds had been white
of Wally West's existence now we know
that Wally West was able to overcome
this by reaching out to Barry Allen and
because Barry Allen remembered Wally
West that Wally seems to be the key to
what's going on in DC rebirth and so
we're effectively following his
character wherever his character happens
to be in order to solve the puzzle of
what it is it's happening right now
but while he also went on and informed
Bruce Wayne of what was happening and so
because of Bruce Wayne's intelligence
he's also working on the project and so
it's more or less Wally just traveling
around grabbing as many people as he can
to basically wake them up and that's
essentially what's happening with the
Titans his first encounter comes in the
form of Dick Grayson because to Wally
West
Dick Grayson was the leader of the
Titans the first person he would wake up
would be their leader also because Dick
Grayson is so wildly intelligent because
Dick Grayson fought alongside Batman for
so many years and so he has the same
kind of training in terms of detective
skills and combat prowess that Batman
has and even Batman himself has said on
multiple occasions that Dick Grayson is
just as good as he is and so because of
this when Wally initially goes to meet
Dick Grayson dick doesn't know who he is
he sees him as an intruder and so where
Dick Grayson goes to attack him Wally
West seems to use the Speed Force to
more or less jumpstart his memories now
this doesn't mean that Dick Grayson
remembers everything and if fact Dick
Grayson says this he says you know I
know your name but I don't know how and
he doesn't give any indication that he
knows anything else about you know who
who Wally West is not Wally says hey man
like we need to find the rest of the
Titans after we find them I'll explain
everything and then all the Titans
descend on him now for Wally West this
is both a horrifying in a situation but
it's also a great situation because real
for him he's going against some very
formidable fighters but at the same time
he's also like these are my friends
they're fighting just like I remember
they're fighting the exact same way that
I remember they're combating you know
the exact same way that I recall this is
the Titans team that I remember now what
Wally does as he goes against each of
these individual members is he basically
takes it in turns to jumpstart their
memories to wake them up now what's also
interesting about this is that he
basically gives us flashback so the most
significant moments when they first met
one another or when they had the most
significant run which when they fought
alongside each other and so it's really
Dan admin is a writer coming back and
saying hey all those great moments that
you remember from the Titans they're all
still here it's just they've all
forgotten about it and so once this
fight comes to an end
Wally really seems to seems to finally
home in seems to finally you know wake
all these individuals up to where they
finally remember who he is now from here
he basically goes through and offers an
explanation to them now when I was first
reading this comic my question was if
nobody remembers Wally West how do they
remember each other because there was no
indication that they ever knew each
other and so if they never knew each
other then why are they here as a team
now Dan Abnett does not give us a lot to
work with here he doesn't offer much in
the way of an explanation all he really
does is he has you know Roy Harper's say
hey it wasn't until recently that we all
remembered each other and so because of
this we're more or less kind of required
to dive back into the original Titans
hunt story in the new 52 to tie back
into this in order to make sure that we
understand everything that's going on
now if you guys want I can probably do a
video series or do a video on Titans
hunt I think it's like eight or eight or
nine issues or something along those
lines
I can't more off top my head but the
fact remains here that the dad admin
also does a really good job of tying in
to current events right now with regards
to DC we worth because as we know with
regards to to all the other characters
who were trying to figure things out
they don't really know exactly what's
going on and so for Wally his idea is
this is a this is a big step if we can
wake up the Titans then that means that
we can try to start moving forward in
the direction of figuring out what's
going on because for him someone came
along and they wiped everyone's memories
of him they tried to keep them apart
because of the fact that the
significant memories of them don't
really apply here and so because of this
his idea is are 8-1
let's let's go find ourselves let's
remember everything let's let's figure
out who we are and once that's done
let's reform our team of the titans and
we can start solving this bigger problem
of who it is that wiped all of you or
wipe me from all of your minds and
that's basically how the story ends it's
effectively Dan Abnett sitting down and
saying okay this this the main story arc
beginning with issues one through six
it's going to be the hunt for who it was
that wiped Wally West's memories from
the mind of everybody and then going
from there
most likely the series would its begin
to lead into whatever this major event
is that focuses on dr. Manhattan but
with that being said hopefully this
video made sense to you guys if you guys
have questions post them down in the
comment section I'll answer them as best
I can
if anybody post questions down there and
some of you guys have really good
answers feel free to answer them as well
because I'm really calling on a lot of
you guys who are knowledgeable about
Teen Titans and the Titans - to help me
answer some questions down there because
I know I know a lot of you guys know a
lot more about those teams than I do but
um in addition to this if you guys are
new here - comments explained make sure
you guys hit the sub button become part
of the robb core and if you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop a like and
yeah I will catch you all later peace
[Music]